and now covert truths frauds and tyrants
first the truths now I told you about
seven weeks ago that hydroxychloroquine
was likely saving lives and now another
study confirms that conclusion and it
was conducted by NYU's Grossman School
of Medicine where researchers looked at
932 kovat patients who are on
hydroxychloroquine along with zinc and
his death through Meissen they concluded
that the triple combo that they have
oiled with that they were 44 percent
less likely to die from the coronavirus
good news
take that FD a second piece of good news
the two states that opened up first
Florida and Georgia both are continuing
to see declines and kovat infections
well shocking the liberal haters but not
to you because we told you that the
virus was probably weakening and that
people would innovate to stay safe and
now on to the frauds let's start with
Pennsylvania health secretary Rachel
Levine who weeks ago ordered nursing
homes to admit kovat positive patients
well while thousands of residents saw
their loved ones and family members die
Levine quietly extracted her own mother
out of harm's way
reportedly moving her from a nursing
home to a hotel
my mother requested and my sister and I
as her children comply to move her to
another location during the kovat 19
outbreak my mother is 95 years old she
is very intelligent and more than
competent to make her own decision I'd
rather have her mother be health
secretary of Pennsylvania frankly well
once again it's liberals like Lavigne
and her boss it's you know it's good for
the same old hypocrisy the rules are for
thee but not for me while the little
people have to suffer under their bad
decisions the connected and the powerful
always have an escape hatch that's what
happened there and since we're on the
fraud Patrol we have to point out
Illinois's own state health director who
at a recent press conference just
casually admitted this
if you were in hospice and had already
been given you know a few weeks to live
and then you also were found to have
kovat that would be counted as a Cova
death even if you died of a clear
alternate cause but you had kovat at the
same time it's still listed as a Cova
death well okay the CDC the state health
offices in these blue states
no wonder the president doesn't trust
their numbers and by the way whatever
happened to one of the worst flu seasons
on record
why are those numbers not tabulated and
actually segregated out so not lumped in
all together in some cases with the Cova
deaths hmm and that brings us to our
tyrants and for this category we stay in
Illinois because billionaire governor JB
Pritzker apparently thinks that he can
save the people of his state by
threatening them especially in counties
that decide to go their own way and get
back to work
the state already provides a lot of
support or cities and counties and so I
would just suggest that there are a
number of enforcement mechanisms that
are available to us and I don't want to
utilize those oh I'm sure he doesn't
maybe Pritzker will invite all the
unemployed in his state to live in his
new 50 million dollar Caribbean getaway
hmm I'll wait for that but what would a
run down of let's say gubernatorial
tyrants be where would they be without
Washington states jay Inslee he's
decided to take cues from China by
empowering an army of government contact
tracers to monitor you
I mean assist you if you get sick and if
you resist don't worry the government
will make sure you have zero reasons to
leave home if they can't get a friend to
do their grocery shopping you we will
help get them groceries in some fashion
if they need pharmaceuticals to be
picked up we can help make sure that
they get their pharmaceuticals isn't
that reassuring and finally we save the
least appealing for last
Michigan's Gretchen witless Whitmer
how to persuade your students to support
this economy crushing shutdown attack
their First Amendment rights and call
them bigots certainly not an exercise of
democratic principles where we have free
speech this is calls to violence this is
racist and misogynistic these protests
you know in a in a perverse way make it
like clear that we're gonna have to stay
in a stay-home posture now aren't you
just clamoring to have her a heartbeat
away from the presidency or maybe as
your attorney general won't that be a
fun world to live in now any of these
blue state control freaks well all of
them they need to keep away from our
children and away from our businesses
heck I don't want them near my dogs at
this point given what they've been
saying and doing it's long past time for
this shutdown to end period